[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily defense attorneys for
a former girlfriend charged in the
murder of a missing mother
want charges dismissed the latest on the
search for jennifer doulos
how the fbi tracked down a suspect in
the capitol riots wanted for assaulting
a police officer
trapped between doors and a nevada court
overturns the conviction of a man
for the murders of his wife and a hired
hitman why he's demanding a speedy trial
i want it done now plus the iowa supreme
court hears arguments in the 10 million
dollar judgment
of a farmer found liable in his mother's
death our experts break down the father
for son
saga and we would ask that this court
reverse and remand this case for trial
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin days after police search again
for the body of a missing mother
her husband's former girlfriend wants
her own charges thrown out
jennifer doulos was reported missing in
may 2019 after dropping her kids off in
connecticut
police became suspicious and then
arrested her husband photos dullos
along with his girlfriend michelle
traconis and friend ken mohini
fotos duolos died last january of an
apparent suicide
draconis and mahini each pled not guilty
to conspiracy to commit murder
trochonus is also facing charges of
evidence tampering
jennifer deulos's body has yet to be
recovered but state police were out of
property this week
searching for clues to her disappearance
a bone-finding expert was seen using
ground penetrating radar to search for
possible remains
at a home in farmington that was owned
by photos duolos's company
our our main goal is to again work
towards providing uh the family of
jennifer doulos
some closure and our detectives will
continue to work tirelessly
after the search an attorney for
michelle draconis filed a motion to
dismiss the evidence-tampering charges
defense attorney john scorehorn claims
truconus's arrest warrant contained
false statements and omitted facts
michelle is innocent of these charges
and we plan to
fight them through the courts
investigators said in the war that
around the time jennifer was reported
missing photos dulos and troconis
stopped 30 times along a busy street in
hartford to dump garbage bags
police recovered some of the bags which
reportedly contained jennifer's blood
and clothing according to the motion
video shows they only stopped three
times
also submitted a photo of mahani at a
meeting with police
over the summer and calls him a
jailhouse informant now
trokonis defense is moving for sanctions
against the state
she's currently out of jail on a two
million dollar bond and must wear an
ankle monitoring device
she's due back in court on february 2nd
joining us is new york city public
defender honor carlson and terry austin
honor you're familiar familiar sorry
with sketchy arrest warrants
what do you make of the defense's motion
so brian
there was really a lot going into the
this original arrest warrant i took a
quick look at it it's a 35-page arrest
warrant and it's filled with detail
um he'll have a lot to overcome
including uh
this this arrest warrant there's an
allegation that they're
going that they're driving through the
city dropping off
bags that rest warrant also continues
contains references to dna found on the
bags
i think one real real problem that he
needs to address squarely
is there's an allegation that miss
shelter conus dna was found on one of
the garbage bags that you can see
being dropped off at one of these
locations so
when they actually did swab those bags
they it's it's not just that she was
along for the ride some of the video
shows her present
in the passenger seat of this car or of
this pickup truck
it's more than that it's that the arrest
warrant contains evidence that she
actually did touch some of these plastic
bags
yeah it's gonna be hard to overcome
terry the question is is this enough to
dismiss the charges
or for sanctions to be handed down
though i don't think so brian i agree
with anna i mean there were some
problems in the arrest warrant but they
weren't significant enough to
dismiss the case or to impose sanctions
you know
under the fourth amendment obviously
there must be probable cause to issue
this arrest warrant
and the courts usually find that
probable cause is there when there's a
reasonable basis for believing that a
crime was committed we have
a reasonable basis here there's no
question that she was in that car
there's no question that she was along
for the ride it doesn't matter if it was
three stops or 30 stops they stopped a
lot maybe they stopped that street light
so
i think that the arrests will be you
know maintained and i don't think
there'll be sanctions
so some discrepancies but maybe not
enough to win the day federal
authorities continue to make arrests
in the storming of the u.s capitol
building
the fbi says patrick mccahe iii is the
man seen here on video
as the mob forced his way through the
front doors crushing a police officer
mukahe was taken into custody in new
york on charges of assaulting an officer
civil disorder entering restricted
building and violent entry
according to court documents mukahi
ripped off the officer's gas mask
exposing his bloodied mouth he's then
accused of using a riot shield to push
against the officer
a childhood acquaintance reportedly
identified makahe to the fbi
police in new york city say they've
arrested a man believed to be behind
a series of murders that targeted older
women 82 year old myrtle mckinney was
found dead from a stab wound in 2015.
then in 2019 in the same senior housing
development
83 year old jacola james was found
dead with highly suspicious injuries and
just
one week ago a third woman 78 year old
juanita cabarello was found dead with
the telephone cord around her neck
police say forensic evidence links kevin
gavin
a neighbor to the homicides mr gavin was
familiar
with many of the residents in the
building and ran errands for some of the
elderly tenants
who resided at that location these women
who are beloved
mothers and grandmothers and neighbors
the fear that has existed in the woodson
houses
regarding what's happening there i am
confident that we have the right person
in custody
and we'll be moving very promptly into
empanelling a grand jury to hear the
evidence in this case
a teenage girl was found stabbed and
laying on the side of the road in 2014.
law and crime's jesse weber looks into
how this shocking crime unfolded in his
new show
prime crime hey thanks brian
coming up on prime crime we revisit the
infamous
slenderman case a 12 year old girl is
brutally stabbed by her classmates in
the name of a fictional horror character
crazy story everyone followed it across
the nation and we're going to break down
the crime scene we'll get into the
motivations and we're really digging
into the shocking statements made by
these girls not only in court
but in their police interrogation tapes
i said
okay how do we do that she said we have
to heal
bella okay
okay and do you know why she said that
like why should she because we
had to supposedly prove ourselves worthy
to
thunder and we ask is it possible that
these attackers could be out free living
amongst the public
tune in at law and crime well make sure
to do that thank you very much jesse
still ahead on law and crime daily could
a 10 million dollar judgment be
overturned
but first a nevada man accused of
murdering his sixth wife
makes his first court appearance since
his conviction was overturned
what he's now demanding after the break
[Music]
a nevada man who's getting a new trial
for the murder of his wife
and alleged hitman is back in court as
law and
angenette levy tells us he's ready for
his new round of legal battles
this was thomas randolph's first time in
a clark county courtroom since being
granted a new trial last month
he wore a mask and a long ponytail he
spoke briefly but directly
i want a speedy trial i want it done now
randolph is accused of murdering his
sixth wife sharon
at their las vegas home in 2008 and then
killing the hitman he hired to kill her
mike miller he had been sentenced to
death for the killings but the nevada
supreme court ordered a new trial
finding the jury should not have heard
testimony about other acts evidence
such as the 1986 death of one of
randolph's wives becky in utah randolph
was acquitted in that case
i think there's some lack of evidence
that is more mind-boggling
in this entire case than anything else
the prosecution really planted seeds in
a las vegas jury
for sharon randolph and mike miller that
he's a serial killer
but there wasn't a lot of evidence to
truly back that up
melissa mccarty and kelly mclear have
exclusive interviews with randolph from
death row
for their new killer jeans podcast it
seems like
everybody and their brother wanted to
bust me for drugs
that's what the uk case is about the
drugs and all the women i had sex with
and it's not criminal it may be not good
if you're married but uh or they're
married but it's not
criminal the times were different back
in the 80s
thomas randolph has an answer for
everything
and it's it's fascinating to hear and
you have to go do you take it with a
grain of salt or
are you taking it as truth and the only
people that knows that truth is thomas
randolph and those that are dead
prosecutors have declined comment but
are moving forward with the retrial
thomas randolph will be back in court on
february 19th with new boyers
and at that time the judge could set a
trial date
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
back for analysis of new york city
public defender honor carlson and
co-host terry austin
terry the theme of the first trial was
that randolph was a serial killer but
if the murder he that he was acquitted
of in that first case in 86
doesn't come in do you think the
prosecution can succeed under some
different theme
well yes i think they can succeed i
think that they can even try to
bring in that murder if they do it the
right way listen
randolph was married six times four of
his wives
died he was tried for the death of his
second wife and he was
acquitted he was then tried and
convicted of you know killing
sharon that was reversed and if they do
this again what the prosecution needs to
do
is focus first of all on the death of
sharon there's
ton of evidence there but second of all
if they want to get
becky's death in there they have to tie
the motive
to the insurance they have to say it was
the same motive with becky as it was
with sharon and i think they can prevail
if they do that
murder for money is a popular theme that
does work anna as a defense attorney if
you picked up this case for a retrial
and i don't know decided to uh
try this case with a random black
canadian from your office how are you
attacking this case
brian i think there's no way this case
doesn't look completely different from
the first trial um
i think if i were defending this case um
in the in the retrial i mean he even
physically looks very different than he
did just three years ago
i i think um what what terry said about
the prosecutor
trying to bring in the prior death as
sort of a modus operandi as his motive
as this is his pattern of killing his
wives
i think they would have a really hard
time bringing that in because he was
acquitted in that in that
uh in that other death i think the
defense would have a powerful argument
that it doesn't even come in as a prior
bad act a court of law
heard about whether there was a bad act
by him and they ruled there was no bad
act he was
not guilty i think um this trial will
look there's no way around it this trial
will look extremely different from the
first trial
yeah that's a that's a bit of a first
for me can you get acquitted of
something but it'd also be considered a
prior bad act
definitely see how that plays out anna
terry thank you for your input
coming up on law and crime daily an iowa
father taking his son to the state's
highest court over the murder
of a loved one a inside look into the
nearly six year legal battle
[Music]
next
[Music]
the iowa supreme court is now deciding
if a son must pay his father 10 million
dollars
over the murder of his mother chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
explains why this drama
is playing out in civil court this is a
family tragedy
jason carter accused by his father bill
carter
of murdering his mother shirley carter
in 2015.
i found shirley on the floor her
hands were crossed and her legs were
crossed
jason came in and i said jason look how
she's laying
you don't die that way he said
some son of a has robbed you and they've
killed mom
what happened was that the criminal
process was going so slowly that the
father
bill carr decided to take matters into
his own hands convinced that his son was
guilty
of the murder he hired his own private
detectives filed the lawsuit and went
ahead
and it was a day and a half after the
verdict in the civil
war where jason carter was found guilty
a day and a half later that the criminal
charges were then filed and he was
arrested
on the charge of first-degree murder i'm
sure to people who are watching
jason carter said all the right things
but we also know that that financial
stress was problematic because he told
terrorists hoke about it
that his credit line being delayed was
something they talked about
so we have all this pressure and
something happens
there's an altercation and shirley
carter dies as a result
there's only two people in this world
who know what happened on june 19 2015
and one of them is dead and the other
one's sitting behind me
we the jury find jason carter not guilty
jason carter was found not guilty in a
criminal trial but he was found guilty
in a civil trial
now his lawyers ask for a new trial from
the iowa supreme court
i don't think either party would agree
to any kind of settlement jason would
certainly never agree to anything that
required him to admit that he murdered
shirley because he didn't
and bill carter seems convinced that
jason was responsible
even despite the quick acquittal that we
achieved in the criminal court
i don't think um settlement is a
possibility for either of these parties
after you were found now guilty was
there any new effort to find
who was in fact guilty since you were
cleared by the jury
we've asked the local prosecutor
and law enforcement to look into
the people you know that
should be held responsible for this are
the people that we believe
uh are responsible
and we were told that nothing
was would ever happen no one was going
to look into anything
when we come back attorneys for jason
carter ask a civil judge to hear
evidence of
other possible suspects why they're
still fighting to clear his name
and why his own father insists he's
guilty
[Music]
welcome back the iowa supreme court is
now considering the
the appeal of a farmer criminally
acquitted of his mother's murder
but found civilly liable attorneys for
jason carter claim evidence was
purposely withheld
for them from them during the original
civil trial
the record in front of you requires
vacation of judgment for three central
reasons
first because jason carter did not have
access to the evidence that was
available
and known to the plaintiffs at the time
of the civil trial
second because the evidence that was
unknown to jason at the time of the
civil trial
was both admissible and reasonably would
have changed the outcome
of the civil trial third
because the district court aired by
allowing the state to provide targeted
seemingly inculpatory evidence to the
plaintiffs and also by refusing to
continue the trial
so that jason carter would have had
access to the exculpatory evidence that
existed
at that time we are asking this court
to reverse and remand this case back to
the district court
for new trial attorneys ricardo's father
bill carter say that that claim is not
true
and that evidence shows jason is guilty
we are now in the sixth year of an
unimaginable
tragedy for a husband and a father bill
carter
we are now in the fourth year of trying
to get finality for the jury verdict
that was returned
in this case it the evidence
overwhelmingly demonstrates that jason
carter killed his mother
and it does so in a way that excludes
almost all of the evidence all of the
evidence that is not
impeaching or cumulative in support of
both the first and the second petitions
to vacate because the petitions to
vacate
both depend although there are lots and
lots of names referenced
on the same fundamental proposition that
some
stranger burglar or burglars surprised
or were surprised by shirley carter in
her house
and in a panic somebody shot shirley
carter
however at the trial of this case both
sides called
extensively credentialed and experienced
crime scene reconstruction experts both
sides
experts agreed that the burglary robbery
scene in the house
was faked and that the the
thing that you could infer from that was
shirley
knew her killer
on rebuttal attorneys for jason carter
say they only learned
of a witness who implicates other
suspects after the civil trial
the new evidence could be used either to
attack
the investigation of law enforcement
or for the purpose of showing the
culpability of other suspects
it's incorrect i believe that that
evidence need to be presented at the
motion to vacate
in its admissible form in at trial
at trial those witnesses would need to
be called but i believe harrington shows
that that information just needs to be
presented in a way that shows it
could lead or would lead to admissible
evidence
and your honor certainly for example
if charity roush was called and she said
i
heard specifically a confession
it was consistent it said they were in
the middle of a burglary
that they were interrupted that they'd
gotten into some of the drawers
and and that shirley carter was shot
twice
those statements made without any
knowledge
of what the testimony was at trial
certainly that could be used to show
that there was culpability of other
suspects
back with me for analysis is honor
carlson and terry austin anna
you heard it there they talked about
what was missing from the first civil
case that they had asked for more time
they'd asked for more investigation and
when it came to the criminal case when
they had all of that
it went in their favor they got an
acquittal what do you think that if
they're armed with those fully developed
facts from the criminal case
do you think that if they got us another
civil trial they would fare better
boy brian this this team is so powerful
and you'll notice
um he has that jason carter has the same
lawyers representing him
in the in the civil retrial that he had
representing him in the criminal trial
you saw the same woman
allison cann or canny i'm sorry i don't
know how to pronounce her name
she's fantastic you saw her making both
arguments um
embracing him when he got the verdict i
think they're going to be incredibly
well versed in the facts from the
criminal trial
and i absolutely think they have a
better shot in the civil trial here
the standard of proof in a civil trial
is much lower than the standard of proof
in a
in a criminal trial in a criminal trial
you need to prove your case beyond a
reasonable doubt and the prosecution
couldn't do that i just can't i can't
see how they think they're going to
prove
to the iowa standard in a civil trial
which is a preponderance of the evidence
slightly more than 50 percent
all right anna i agree with you but
terry you're the civil expert in this
panel of public defenders
is this going to work for jason carter
or will the original ruling stand
i think the original ruling will stand
my educated guess is that jason carter
will lose
this motion as my columbia law school
professor used to say
too bad so sad he had a civil case
and he lost that case now he has a
criminal case
and the point is one has nothing to do
with the other
as anna said there is definitely a
different
standard of proof it's two different
burdens
two different outcomes and what happens
in the civil trial has nothing to do
with the criminal trial
unless you know there's reversible error
or new information all right thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you